[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-My name is Andrea Zapata.
I'm 16 years old.
I'm from Minnesota, and
I have cystic fibrosis.
Cystic Fibrosis is
a genetic disease
that makes the secretions
in my body thicker.
That's why my lungs and
sinuses get full of mucous
and infected.
My pancreas doesn't
produce the enzymes
that help to digest my
food and the insulin
to keep my sugars stable.
And my liver gets
full of stones.
There's no cure for
cystic fibrosis yet.
But there's a lot
of treatments that I
have to take to stay healthy.
For example, I have to take
four of these with every meal
so I digest my food properly.
And these are vitamins.
Some are for my liver, and
for a bunch of other things.
This is not even a week of
pills that I have to take.
This is my nebulizer.
I use it from three
to four times a day,
and twice a day with my vest.
Together they help
me to keep my lungs
clear and without infection.
I also have to get IV
antibiotics from three to four
times a year.
And because my veins don't
work property anymore,
I recently had to get a
Port-a-Cath implanted, which
is this little bump right here.
And my mom just puts
a little needle in it,
and the treatment lasts
from two to three weeks.
Last year, after a rough couple
of months in the hospital,
my doctors introduced
me to Make-A-Wish,
and they helped me to apply.
I was so shocked
because I couldn't
believe that they could
take my lifetime dream
and make it come true.
A lot of people ask me why
I chose Google as my wish.
It wasn't because the offices
looked cool on the moves.
Google is so much more than
what everyone imagines.
For me, it was an inspiration
to see the Googlers work hard
every day to make
people's lives easier
with big smiles on their faces.
The adventure has started
here in Venezuela,
when my family and I
got onto the plane,
and the pilot came
to my seat and asked
me to go with him to the cabin.
He explained to me
how everything works.
We took selfies, and it
was a really nice surprise.
Make-A-Wish also made
possible for my brother
to go, which made the
experience so much better,
since he's a student in England.
They let us explore the
whole city of San Francisco,
and we got to see a lot
of wonderful places.
The first place that
we visited was Verb.
I was so confused because I
hadn't heard of that company
before.
But I'm so thankful that I did.
Ethan, Brian, and
[INAUDIBLE] explained to us
everything that they
were working on.
And I was so
impressed to see how
they create tools
that fit in perfectly
within people's health needs.
I also asked them to keep
cystic fibrosis in mind
because I hope that one day they
can create something to help CF
patients all around the world.
Then we met Andrew, an amazing
Googler from Google Fit.
I had the opportunity to ask him
a few questions about Google,
and he was so pleased
and glad to answer them,
as I was to hear them.
He also gave me some pretty
cool gifts, like Moto 360.
Right before going to lunch,
we took a lot of pictures
with Stan, the dinosaur.
Then we had lunch
at Charlie's Cafe,
which is the most popular
cafe in Googleplex.
I had the best burrito
that I have ever
had in my entire life.
After this is when I saw
one of the things that
really impressed me,
the conference bicycle.
It fits six people, and
they have meetings in there,
while riding around campus.
How cool is that?
Then we met Grace, who
works at the Chrome office.
And besides how great she
was, she gave me a Nexus 5.
I was so excited.
One of the most unbelievable
things that I saw
was this self-driving car.
I never imagined that I
would get on one of them.
It was so crazy to
see how well it works.
Sadly, the day was over.
We went to Google
merchandise store,
where I got this cooler, this
pen, this mouse pad, and Alisha
gave me this t-shirt.
I have no words to thank
Make-A-Wish, especially
Jessie and Sasha, for
making my wish come true
and letting me enjoy this
wonderful week with my family,
along with Katie and Alicia, and
every single person in Google
who shared their
experiences and time with me
and made it the
best day of my life.
I can't forget to thank
my amazing medical team
at the University of
Miami Cystic Fibrosis
Center-- my doctors, my
nurses, my therapists,
my social worker, and especially
[? Alisa ?], [INAUDIBLE],
and Andrew for always helping me
to stay as healthy as possible
and who introduced
me to Make-A-Wish.
I hope that you can keep
making every wish of every kid
all around the world come
true and you can make
them feel like feel right now.
Now I know that
wishes do come true.
[END PLAYBACK]
NIGEL BARKER: Wow.
I don't about you, but a
round of applause for that.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT TARGETT: How do
you follow that, right?
NIGEL BARKER: I don't
know how you follow it.
I mean, first of all, to
have that much attention
with a camera on
your face-- and I
know from talking on
television, you always
want it to push off and
show all the B roll moments.
But actually, she was as
fascinating, if not more.
Wow, what a character.
If she gets to work for
Google, I think you're lucky.
MATT TARGETT: One
day, hopefully.
Well, thankfully we have
some B roll to save us.
But I do have a welcome
and a bio for everybody.
So welcome to another
Talks at Google.
Nigel, I have your bio here.
You seem like a bit of an
overachiever, so I'll--
NIGEL BARKER: Don't
believe it all.
MATT TARGETT: So for
those who don't know,
Nigel Barker's an
internationally renowned
photographer who opened his
New York studio in 1996.
He's most famous for serving 17
seasons as "America's Next Top
Model" judge and then
became into "The Face"
with Naomi Campbell.
And now has his own radio show,
"Radio Andy" in a couple hours
actually.
You have two books, "The Beauty
Equation" and "The New York
Times" best-selling
"Models of Influence,"
which came out last year.
You live here in New York
City with your wife Cristen,
half of the Chin twins, and
your two kids, Jack and Jasmine.
Welcome.
NIGEL BARKER: Thank
you very much.
That's very sweet of you.
Thank you.
Well, that means, by the
way, is that I'm old.
That's all.
MATT TARGETT: I was
going to get to that.
So you've been in New
York for 20 years.
But there's a life before that
that took you to New York City.
Can you take us through that?
NIGEL BARKER: Yeah,
well, certainly,
very quickly, I was a
lucky kind of character.
I think a lot of things happened
for me that sort of set me up
for where I am sort of today.
I'm a born and bred
Londoner from Chelsea.
But I come from a mixed
background, mixed family.
And I started-- growing
up in the '70s in England
as part Sri Lankan,
part English,
I was one of the only
kids that sort of looked
my way in my neighborhood.
And at the school I went to
there were very few mixed kids.
Of course, now when I look
across almost any audience,
you have a beautiful array
of color and different types.
But that wasn't
the case, certainly
not in the '70s in London.
And that was one
of the reasons why
I was very interested
in exploring the world.
And I know you're an Australian.
And Australians love
to travel the world
and see what the rest
of the world's like.
I think England's a
similar thing-- an island,
and people trying
to get off quickly.
And certainly, myself,
I always-- who am I?
What am I?
And the fashion world
intrigued me very early on.
At school, I'd been interested
in things like fashion design
and pattern cutting and
tailoring and weaving
and photography and art.
Yet I was predisposed to be
better at math, sciences,
and so I was going to be
a doctor because that's
what everyone says you
should be because you can be.
But it wasn't what
interested me.
And so for me, as
fate would have it,
there was a show on
television in England
called "The Clothes Show."
And it's rather an
ironic situation
because it's one of the very
first televised model searches
ever, in the '80s.
And I didn't win, but
my mother entered me
onto this TV show, which ended
up with me getting a contract
to become a model that I
decided I do for a year
in between medical school,
raise a little bit of money
before going back.
One year lead two.
Be careful, parents,
what you allow
your kids to do because
financial independence meant
after two years, that when
they said, OK, now you
need to go to school and study
medicine, I said, well, see ya.
And I disappeared into Europe
and hung out in Milan and Paris
and enjoyed that world
and became a photographer
eventually, when things changed
in the mid-'90s, and I realized
I was not hair and chic
androgynous or ever going to be
a waif model.
And I didn't want to throw
away the six years of history
I'd had in modeling, so.
MATT TARGETT: Interesting.
So it sort of seems like
your life came full circle.
Your mother was a
Miss Sri Lanka winner?
NIGEL BARKER: She was, yeah.
MATT TARGETT: And you just
judged the Miss USA contest.
NIGEL BARKER: I have been a
judge of many beauty pageants,
one way or another, whether
it's modeling or you
"The Face" with Naomi Campbell,
"Top Model" with Tyra,
obviously, Miss Universe
with the Donald.
And I've recently done Miss
USA, Miss World, you name it.
If there's been a
pageant, I think
I might be the most
qualified beauty pageant
judge in the world, if
that's an actual title.
I think I've done
more than most,
which is really weird
because it's not actually
not how my mind thinks
or how I like to operate.
I'm not really a
judgemental guy.
But one way or the other.
I've been involved with that.
MATT TARGETT: That's
super interesting.
And I imagine "America's
Next Top Model," 17 seasons,
was a real career accelerator
that allowed you to do that.
NIGEL BARKER: It's funny.
It's one of those things--
yes, absolutely, right.
It was a risk
thought at the time,
and I think that
that's what's something
that people don't often see.
You often look at things
with hindsight, like, OK,
that was obviously a good idea.
Well done for doing that.
I didn't know it was necessarily
a brilliant idea at the time.
It was a risk, and
I'll tell you why.
Back then, when I first got
involved with "Top Model,"
the show was on a
small network, UPN,
that doesn't exist anymore.
Fashion was extremely
elite and exclusive.
And it was all
about the "Vogues"
and the "Harper's Bazaars"
and the big designers.
And to leave that world
to go on primetime
was a huge commercial
step, and I was sort of
at the brink of
a sort of moments
in my career which
were up and coming.
And big designers
were calling me.
Jil Sander of Versace
was getting a lot
of big breaks in editorial.
And so it was a risk.
However, as a young man trying
to break into it in New York,
I thought, well, how am I
going to get my name out there?
I might do one or two big jobs.
But then it might
just fade away.
This is new.
This is novel.
And this is really
pre-Instagram, pre-Facebook,
pre a lot of everything
that anyone was used to,
really pre the internet,
to some extent.
I mean, it was obviously there.
But it was very early days.
Yet I kind of always
liked the idea
that we could crack open the
doors of the fashion industry
and open it to people so they
could see really how it worked.
It had changed my life.
I had found a place where
I wasn't being questioned
about where I was from,
why I looked different,
why I liked fashion.
Was I gay?
Was I straight?
None of that mattered.
It had to do with my talent
and who I was as a person.
And I felt that other people
should learn about that
and should find out about it.
And that the fashion
industry is, in fact,
a place where there's a
lot of misfits and people
who had a difficult
childhood who find themselves
in the fashion industry,
and they find a home there
because they're not judged
for any of those things
I just mentioned.
And that, I thought,
was important.
And I like that
about "Top Model."
And, hey, it went on from being
a small show to being a cult
phenomenon, that we
were in 146 countries,
with a weekly viewership
of over 100 million people
watching the show.
It became the largest
television export
out of the United
States, beating
"Sesame Street" and "Baywatch."
So there you go.
Watch out.
MATT TARGETT: Sorry,
David Hasselhoff.
NIGEL BARKER: Grover.
MATT TARGETT: So you spoke
about diversity before.
That's important in fashion.
Obviously, a big topic,
and those companies
are doing it well and
really reaping the benefits.
Amongst your 1.2 million
followers on Google+,
how have you built your
brand in today's world right?
You mentioned TV was the
only outlet back then.
Now you have so
many more outlets
and mediums to consider.
NIGEL BARKER: Absolutely.
I think that ultimately what
the most important thing,
and I think one
of the reasons why
I was somewhat well-positioned
to take advantage
of social media,
is that if you're
going to be successful
on reality television,
and it's one of the reasons
why I think certain reality
shows don't work, is because of
the authenticity of the cast.
And that one of the reasons why
"Top Model" was a huge success
is that when Tyra asked me to
come on, I was nobody, really.
I mean, I was me.
And I was a photographer.
And I was her friend.
And I did what I did.
But that's all.
And I think that was
also the genius of her
casting me to be that part.
She could have found
someone, perhaps,
who was better known or more
of a television personality.
But, likewise, with
Miss J and Jay Manuel
and all the other
people she involved,
they were really here
makeup artist, the person
who taught her to walk around.
They were the real deal.
Everyone did that job.
And I think that oftentimes
in reality television now
you'll find judges and
people who are famous
and they're already a celebrity.
That doesn't really
resonate in the long term.
And I felt that our
truthfulness and reality worked.
And that also works
in social media.
And I've always applied
that, as in, who am I?
What am I about?
And that is the message that I
put out there on social media.
So if it's my family, if
it's about my emotion,
if it's about something I
see, some advice I have,
I give it freely and openly.
And I don't try and kind of
wrap it or produce it or make it
look extra glossy or anything.
It has to have all
the reality behind it.
And I think that
the good reality
shows, like a "Top
Model," were all
about the behind the
scenes, which is really
what so much of social
media is based on
is the behind the scenes
and that learning process.
So we were already kind
of plugged into that.
And that's helped me regardless
of whether I understand all
social media, and I don't.
Have the time, I'm
completely confused
by how these things work and
why they do what they do.
But I do love the interaction.
And I've always been
fascinated in people.
MATT TARGETT: Absolutely.
So how do you stay authentic
in today's day and age?
I noticed the other
foundations you
work with are largely align
with who you are as a person.
And why did you
choose Make-A-Wish?
NIGEL BARKER: I didn't
choose Make-A-Wish.
I think the reality is
Make-A-Wish chose me.
And I think that's the
thing about Make-A-Wish.
Make-A-Wish chooses everybody.
And one of the wonderful
things about the Make-A-Wish
Foundation is that when
you're asked to grant a wish,
you inadvertently have
your own wish granted.
And it's a wish that
you didn't realize
you wanted to have granted.
It's sort of the weirdest thing.
When I first got
asked, there I was.
I was on this television
show. "Top Model"
is being super successful.
And this young girl, her wish
was to be a model for the day.
And she knew of me because
she watched the show.
And if she could have this
wish, who better for her
at that moment then to have the
guy from the television show
take the picture?
That was the guy she knew.
And I was honored
enough to be asked.
It was as simple as that.
And I thought, sure, I'll
do it-- very flippant,
a bit really.
I was young and excited
about everything
that was going on in my career.
I really didn't
understand the full impact
this was going to have on me.
And I say this
because it was one
of those extraordinary
moments, Matt,
where I had this young girl
who'd flown in to New York.
She'd had all the star
treatment of staying
in a wonderful hotel, and
she'd been flown over.
And a limo had taken
her to the studio.
We're shooting in
this wonderful space.
She's excited.
She's only all of 13 years old.
She had had a type of cancer
and multiple operations,
and her arm was all shriveled.
And she was an
incredible character.
But one half of her body was
all really, kind of deformed
and withered away.
And the other half
seemed normal.
And I remember her standing
in front of me in this dress.
And she stood there with her arm
all withered, and there's me,
the photographer, thinking,
OK, I see this withered arm.
I see the other side
looking perfect.
Let me take a couple
of frames of her here.
Then I'll turn her around, and
we'll get the perfect shot.
She let me take a couple
of frames of her like that.
Then I said, OK, Nicole,
would you turn around?
And she looked at me, and she
said, I don't really want to.
And I sort of smiled and said,
oh, well, we've got this side.
Let's get the other side.
But she was very savvy.
And she looked at me
straight in the eyes.
I remember to this day.
It's down the
barrel of my lenses,
these beautiful blue eyes,
deep and they were sad,
but they were positive,
and they were confident,
and they were real.
And she looked to me
and said, do you know?
I don't want to.
This is why I'm here.
This is my story.
This is a part of me.
And it was a defining moment.
Here I am, a man
who defined himself
by searching for beauty,
telling people what was pretty,
what was not, how to be a
model, all the rest of it.
And a little girl
of 14 years old
made me see for the first
time what true beauty was.
The courage, the
bravery in that moment
alone redefined my
concept of beauty,
and it set me on a
trip forever after,
of searching for that kind of
person, that kind of beauty.
In the films that I
filmed and the charities
I've been involved with, it's
about those kinds of people.
That they move me,
and they're the ones
who make me fall
in love with people
and life and the potential.
And she became a
lifelong friend.
I was incredibly in
awe of this young girl,
and I followed her career.
And in fact, when she went to
college and she went to Parsons
and she graduated, I actually
collaborated with her
on her first exhibition,
where I put her art
into my photographs.
And we did a show in New York
City, which she opened with.
And we did a complete
sold-out show of all her work,
and it was phenomenal.
And for me, my wish is being
granted over and over again.
And I've noticed that with
everybody who I've got involved
is that you won't believe how
life changing Make-A-Wish is
for everybody involved.
And it takes a village
to do these wishes.
It's not a one-man a band.
MATT TARGETT: Yeah, absolutely.
I was going to get to that.
There's a lot of volunteers
behind the scenes.
People obviously
donate their money
and also donate airline miles.
I know United Airlines is
offering a donation match.
NIGEL BARKER: Absolutely.
MATT TARGETT: You
said it takes an army,
and summer is the busiest
time for Make-A-Wish.
Can you go over that for a sec?
NIGEL BARKER:
Absolutely, well, there's
no doubt that summer
is obviously, as far as
weather-related and
everything else, the summers
are always an important time.
And of course, kids are out
of school and more available.
And parents tend to perhaps
have vacation time and things
like that.
So there's a realness to the
actual timing of these things.
And there's a campaign
that Make-A-Wish
has called Wishes Can't Wait.
And there's a couple of things
about Make-A-Wish, first
of all, that I'd just
like to say, too.
That people often
think that the children
who are having their wishes
granted have terminal illness.
Sometimes that's the case.
But it's not the
story of Make-A-Wish.
Make-A-Wish is
about children with
life-threatening illnesses.
And reality is that many times
the actual wishes themselves--
and this is what doctors have
said over and over again--
have given the children
a sense of hope,
an ability to dream,
like you heard
of this young girl who
was talking just now,
that wishes do come true.
And when you live a life
from an early age of pain,
suffering, medication,
hospital visits, you often
don't know what it
means to be a child.
You don't realize what it's
like to wish and to dream
and to fantasize about
what could happen
or what the future's
going to look like.
And all of a sudden, when
you experience something
like this young girl
did of going to Google
and seeing how you live and
what you're doing for the world,
and she thinks, goodness,
that could be me.
I might have a
chance to do that.
That moment for a
child can give them
the courage and the enthusiasm
and the wish and the desire
to actually heal
themselves from within,
and to make the opportunity
and optimism itself.
It's not a medical thing.
It's not a medication.
It's hard to quantify.
But doctor after doctor after
doctor have lined up and said,
there is a reason why we refer
our patients to Make-A-Wish.
It's not just because
we feel that they
should have a fun time, because
it's cute, because it's nice.
It's because it
actually literally
can turn the patients around.
So the summer is
an important time
to get activated,
to get motivated.
And Because some
children, too, it
might be their only opportunity.
And I feel that we act now.
We act as fast as
you can and don't
wait for someone to
ask you, but to get
involved as soon as you can.
MATT TARGETT: Absolutely.
We actually have a video of one
of your wishes being granted
that was shown at
the Make-A-Wish gala
The Power of the Wish.
Can we show that, please?
NIGEL BARKER: Show it, please.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I've been shooting wishes with
Make-A-Wish now for 10 years.
And I've seen
firsthand what a wish
can do for a child battling
a life-threatening illness.
It can heal their spirit,
give them strength to fight,
and give them back a bit of
power over their own lives
when all seems out of control.
-Oh, here we go.
Hey, Pauline, how are you?
-Hi, Good.
How are you?
-I'm very well.
I'm very well indeed.
-Make-A-Wish has been great.
Colleen never would
have had a chance
to do something like
this without it.
-We've waited for a long
time, and I didn't really
think that she would be able
to have her dream come true.
-Colleen and Camille,
this was their wish.
-Hello!
-Hi, guys!
-How are you doing?
Nice to meet you!
-Nice to meet you, too.
-How are you?
-They wished that they
could be a model for a day.
-First of all, I just want
to give you a big welcome,
a big Milk welcome.
Today is all about you
doing exactly what you want.
When it comes to modeling,
this is your day.
But I'd like to
introduce you to someone
who's very, very important,
someone who's granted wishes
with me for many, many years.
His name is Rassi, and he is,
of course, the owner of Milk,
and he's back there.
-Milk Studios have provided the
most incredible studio space,
all the equipment for free.
When you see all the different
people who have come together
to make it happen, from
my hair and makeup teams,
the stylist who's pulled
clothes for the past week,
the designers who've given
all the different outfits
and the accessories
and the shoes,
these people highlight the
best and brightest aspects
about collective humanity.
They are the true heroes that
make wishes happen every day.
-All right, let's get
this party started.
[APPLAUSE]
-Going in here, I didn't
no what to expect.
I mean, I knew I was
taking a couple photos,
but, like, this is amazing.
The wardrobe was great.
The shoes, the jewelry, like
that was so freaking cool.
-It was really fun, because
I was like really nervous
beforehand because I
didn't know what to expect.
I'd never done it before.
But then when I was there,
I wasn't really thinking.
I wasn't really nervous.
It was just fun.
My favorite part was probably
the actual modeling with Nigel.
-Look at you,
Colleen, my goodness!
I don't know who'd more
excited, you or me.
[LAUGHTER]
-It was really fun.
I feel like I'm more confident.
I would do it again if
I got the opportunity.
-I chose this wish because
I want to be a model.
It was a great
experience, and I love it.
It was great.
-The whole weekend
has been great.
And it's something that
she's going to remember,
and we'll all remember it.
-It is surreal.
It's like a dream.
-When they put those gowns
on and they transform
with their hair and
makeup and nails,
they've dreamt of this moment.
And looking forward
to this day, it's
let them dream
beyond those hospital
walls and the treatment.
And it's a day they
will remember forever.
I must say, I feel
extremely blessed
to have had the
opportunity to photograph
these extraordinary girls.
-My sister's best
friend, her brother,
was a Make-A-Wish candidate.
Thinking back to the smile
that was on Tyrone's face
and how the girls
today smiled, it just
put a smile in my heart.
-These young ladies
were as beautiful
inside as they are outside.
It was a total honor to
do their makeup today,
-This is something that, as
photographers and stylists,
we do every day.
But today is special
because of the impact
it will have on these two
girls and their families.
-I don't think people realize
the value of giving like they
should. [CRYING] And for
folks who would take time out
of their schedule for
us to have this space
and this opportunity,
that's indescribable.
And I'm just thankful.
-Thank you to all the
heroes who make each wish
possible and unforgettable.
[END PLAYBACK]
MATT TARGETT: Wow. that's the
third time I've seen this,
and I just noticed Crissy's
face in the background.
NIGEL BARKER: Oh, you did?
MATT TARGETT: Yeah,
the very first time.
I can't believe I missed it.
NIGEL BARKER: That's
my wife, by the way.
So we've been
together for 22 years.
Yeah, she's there behind--
she's not just behind me.
The reality is in my life,
she's not just next to me,
she's really in front of me.
I wouldn't be here in this
position if it weren't for her.
MATT TARGETT: Yeah, you
guys are a great team.
I noticed you used your
platform to sort of launch
their social media,
the Chin twins.
I think they have 50,000
followers in around about
a year?
NIGEL BARKER: That's right.
50.6 as of today, yes.
It can be done.
MATT TARGETT: Absolutely.
I guess part of the question
I had earlier I didn't get to
was the considerations
going into,
you obviously have a photo
of tremendously high quality,
and then you
transform it online.
It loses some of that
quality, the shape.
What are the considerations
you have for photos
and also for videos?
NIGEL BARKER: For shooting for
Instagram and for social media
in general?
I don't over
analyze these ideas.
I still put my heart and
soul into everything I do.
And it's funny.
It doesn't matter
whether it's literally
what people might think is
the most random shot or not.
I still really care about it
and analyze it and look at it
and feel for it
and feel passion.
And whatever I'm
shooting, even if it's
a photograph, like you said,
for my wife's Instagram account,
I'll really apply as
much production value
as I can put into it.
And that's really
mostly just caring.
I think the caring
aspect is really
at the highest level of
production you can ever have.
If you don't care, then it
doesn't matter how much money
you slap on to the side of it.
You don't really care
about the end product.
And you can see that with big
TV shows and all the rest of it.
Going to "Top
Model," when we first
started shooting that,
we had $2 million,
I think, for the first
season to do the entire show.
By the time we got to the end
of shooting like 17 seasons,
we were getting like $2 million
for our catering budget.
So it was a very different--
but show wasn't better.
In fact, our ratings
weren't even as high
as they were when
we had less money.
So that speaks to
the fact that it
isn't about the money, often.
It's about the heart and soul.
MATT TARGETT: Tying this
back to Make-A-Wish,
sometimes it is about the money.
You just hosted the
Power of a Wish Gala.
You livestreamed it
for the first time
and raised over a $1 million.
Can you describe
what that felt like?
NIGEL BARKER: It felt amazing.
It felt fantastic.
And I think galas are one
of those interesting things.
It's something that's very
much a sort of a tradition
of raising money.
And certainly in New
York, the gala world,
the gala season opens up, and
every night there's a gala.
Sometimes there's more than
one gala, and you're competing.
And who's made what?
And people are there with all
their money and flashiness
and all the rest of it.
But one of the things
that we wanted to do,
and one of my missions
certainly, with Make-A-Wish,
and I know that Make-A-Wish
follows me with this too,
is that it isn't just about
a few wealthy people getting
involved, that Make-A-Wish
has always been inclusive.
And to open the gala
and stream it live
and to invite the public,
really, into the gala,
to be able to be a part of it,
was important for Make-A-Wish
and myself.
And it was the first time
they'd ever done that.
And I feel that going
forward, the gala itself
will evolve into a far more
inclusive and involved event.
That really the
Gala ends up being
a kickoff for a larger
campaign that people
can be more involved with.
Versus sort of one night
of fund raising, it
needs to be an ongoing event.
And as we've said multiple
times, it takes an army.
It takes a village.
All these wishes are
created by everybody
getting involved and
playing their part,
from feeding people to
driving people over,
to all the little aspects.
Maybe you're donating
your air miles,
or you yourself are
donating your time.
Time is the one
thing that we need.
It isn't the money.
The money is fantastic.
And yes, we need money
for infrastructure
and for elements of it.
But unless you've
got the person there
willing to share--
these children
aren't asking for money.
They're not asking for you to
pay for this or pay for that.
All they really want, and what
any of us ever really want,
is someone to listen
and to care and to stop
for a second in that busy life
that they lead and to focus.
And I think that
focus is something
which we can't put a dollar
value on, but it's invaluable.
And that's something which we
all have the ability to do.
So if you want to be the
highest donor at any gala,
all you have to do
is donate your time.
And you've done more than the
guy that's given $100,000.
MATT TARGETT: Absolutely.
So this is going to be the
last question before we open up
for the aisle mics, and
Gina from Make-A-Wish
is going to join.
So $413.19, what does
that mean to you?
NIGEL BARKER:
That's my daughter.
My young seven-year-old
took me by surprise,
and with her class,
they did a food court.
Basically, it's like an
elaborate lemonade stand, where
they made pizzas and
lemonades and smoothies,
and they sold it
to their classmates
and to parents who came by.
But they raised $417.13,
whatever the number was.
But I had no idea who
she was raising it for,
other than the fact
that she was doing it.
And then she said,
they decided, the class
has decided en masse to give
them money to Make-A-Wish,
which was a very sweet gesture.
And she had had to convince
her class of doing this.
But she'd never come to me and
asked me for any information
or whether she should
or she shouldn't.
But she'd stood in
class and decided
to get up and
convince everybody.
And she sort of told the
story of Make-A-Wish,
that she'd heard
from me, and managed
to convince unilaterally
the entire class to do it.
And all of a sudden, they were
all talking about Make-A-Wish.
And at the gala, we had five
or six of her classmates
come to the gala
and take a table
and sit there, at seven years
old, with all these adults
around them, listening.
And she came up on to stage,
and she gave the money away.
It was a wonderful moment
because it really made people
everywhere, not
just at the gala,
but everyone watching
through Facebook Live
or what have you,
at that moment,
realize, OK, if a little girl
can do this and spend her time
and realize that she can make
a difference, then I can too.
I think that was powerful.
MATT TARGETT: Absolutely.
So it's obvious you're
an incredible role
model, amazing fashion
sense, t-shirt,
jacket, like well done.
NIGEL BARKER: I got the memo.
Sorry I wore socks,
is all I can say.
I didn't-- I got
the Google thing.
MATT TARGETT: It's all right.
You're old.
You said it yourself.
NIGEL BARKER: Yeah, thank you.
MATT TARGETT:
First of all, thank
you so much for being here.
Before we stop for
questions, I really
want to thank you for being
here and spending your time.
Gina, can we have
you on stage, please?
NIGEL BARKER: Do we
need another chair?
Oh, that's brilliant..
I might just move my chair,
so I don't back to you.
GINA FLORESCU: It's hard
to share it with you.
Hi, there.
MATT TARGETT: So the
Wishes Can't Wait Campaign,
can you take us
through that please?
GINA FLORESCU: Sure.
So I'm Gina Florescu.
I'm the head of Communications
and Marketing at Make-A-Wish.
And we really have some
great things to work with,
and Nigel has helped us
do so many great things.
And it opens the
door for us to be
able to really talk much
more deeply about what
we do from day to day.
Because I think although people
know Make-A-Wish, they don't.
I don't think they realize
how much we're just
in your community
from day to day.
So our summer campaign is
really off of the gala.
One of the things we did
in the gala is really
want to make sure that
everybody understood
that what we're doing,
not just in New York
or Make-A-Wish nationwide, but
really understand that we're
in your community,
that these kids,
they might be your
neighbors, or they
might be somebody who your
children go to school with.
And that it's really important
that everyone knows that they
can play a part in it.
We've done a lot of work to
try to get people to understand
the impact and how that
goes through a community
and how everyone's impacted.
So what we did in
the gala is really
start talking about the
boroughs and the work
that we do in each
of the boroughs.
In New York City we
have five boroughs.
We also work in Nassau County,
and each of those Boroughs
has a tremendous
group of hospitals,
a tremendous amount of health
care workers who help us,
volunteers who help us.
The community that
usually, when they
know a kid is sick in their
community, they rally around
and help out.
So we wanted to start really
going deeper into what
that impact looks like.
And so we talked about
the boroughs at our gala,
and we brought that through
in a boroughs campaign.
But it was really being
able to really look
at summer is our busiest time.
We have over 200 wishes to
grant this summer, which
makes us internally very busy.
But that means our
volunteers and our outreach,
everything has to ramp up.
Our fundraising has to ramp up.
And we wanted
people to understand
that it's really urgent.
We say wishes can't wait because
these kids have gone through--
quite often they've gone through
some tremendous treatment.
They've gone through
months, if not
years, of trying to get better
or deal with an illness.
They've waited they.
And they've been able to
get this wish granted.
Sometimes it is that
case where they're
looking at this wish all
along, and it helps them heal.
It helps them with hope.
It helps bring their
family back together
when they're going through
a tremendous crisis.
And quite often a wish
is that crowning piece
that they get to go do
something with their family.
And that happens a lot in the
summer because they can travel.
So they can't wait
because these kids have
gone through-- they've
gone through so much
to get where they are.
And we can't let them wait
another season to do that.
But we also in our Wishes
Can't Wait campaign, each week,
we take a story of
a child and tell you
what they've gone through and
why their wish can't wait.
And we tell it where the
borough that they're from
and what the
hospitals are there,
how they help us so
much with outreach, how
those medical professionals
help us reach those kids
and teach those kids
about what a wish can do,
and about the volunteers
that are in the community.
So we really try to tell a
little bit about each community
as well.
Again, really showing
everybody that it takes
a lot of different people.
And you can probably, in the
stories, find yourself in it.
MATT TARGETT: Absolutely.
We're going to have the website
for information and donations
as well.
So there's 350,000 wishes
granted worldwide, right?
Are there any that
stand out to you?
I think everyone's heard
of that Bat Kid and SF.
But are there are any
that are lesser known?
NIGEL BARKER: I think
one of the things
that I find fascinating is,
listen, there's definitely
that big wishes, right?
There these fantastic
over-the-top wishes,
like in Chicago and
they shut the city down,
and everyone gets
involved, and it's
super glamorous and over the
top, and you're like, wow.
And that wish is fantastic.
It's obviously great
for press, and everyone
gets to hear about it, and
the kid has this amazing wish,
and other kids are
like, wow, that's cool,
and they hear about Make-A-Wish.
That's the wonderful
thing there.
But what for me, what I found
fascinating about Make-A-Wish,
and the wishes in general,
is that the children are just
children.
And what they wish for
is very specific to them,
and they're not always massive.
Children come from all
different walks of life.
And some of them
have these dreams
because they're into
a superhero and they
want to be a superhero.
But others, their wishes
can be very simple.
And I've known of
wishes where kids
have wanted to go to a farm to
touch an animal because they
live in an urban environment,
and they've never actually
been to a farm.
And they've only ever
seen sort of animals
on television or in a book or
on the shelves of a supermarket,
literally.
And they would like to go.
Or they want to go to the
beach and feel the water
between their toes in the sand.
And you're like,
that's your wish?
It's just to go to the beach?
But I don't belittle it.
The reality is that
for that child,
they've never seen a horizon.
They've lived in
hospital rooms, where
they've only ever seen a wall
and a TV that's in the thing.
And for them, all
of a sudden, just
to see the sunset on the
water and to hear the water
and to see the sand,
it's only something
they've seen in a film.
Then you realize that that
is a beautiful moment,
yet it could be life
changing for them.
And we take it for granted.
Those wishes, I think,
are so powerful.
And they're no less powerful
than the big wishes, which
is, again, the reason why
we all have the opportunity
to get involved.
Sometimes when you see
these gigantic wishes,
you're like, well, heck, I
couldn't have pulled that off.
But there are things you can
do that can make a difference.
GINA FLORESCU: There was a
great wish that we had recently.
It does embody sort of
what children go through
and how they're actually
trying to come up
with a wish that
really comes out
of their creativity and heart.
Because we're a
New York City, we
do what are called
"wish assists."
So other chapters who are
coming, who have wishes,
they come to New York
and we assist them.
This kid wanted
to ride elevators.
It was elevators and
push elevator buttons.
And the genesis is,
to a certain degree,
because he'd always
been in hospitals.
And he always wanted
to touch those buttons.
And he's lying down.
He can see the exit signs, and
his world was very different.
He was a nonverbal kid.
But this is what
he wanted to do.
So they set up this
brilliant wish.
Macy's let him in
before it opened,
and they let him
click the switch that
started those old wooden
escalators going up the middle.
He'd had never seen
anything like it.
And then he took some of the
different elevators around.
And then there was
the freight elevator,
where he's standing there,
and it opens up sideways.
And there's this man
standing in there,
and this kid was so enamored,
like I said, he was non-verbal,
but at the end, he sort
of made this motion.
And his mom said,
oh, he wants a hug.
So this big elevator operator
who had no idea what his day
was going to be like when
he walked in that day,
you know he's never
going to forget that.
NIGEL BARKER: He was a hero.
GINA FLORESCU: He was a hero.
But again, I'm sure his wish
was granted that day too.
It's amazing how
much it touched.
So they went through several
other tall buildings,
and I don't remember
what they were.
But those things
are pretty common,
that we hear stories like that.
NIGEL BARKER: The
value that everybody
feels having granted a
wish-- the wishes that I've
heard of kids who wanted
go bake bread, for example.
And you look-- They
love the smell of it,
and they've never
actually seen the process.
And the kids are
fascinated with process.
And I have two little children.
They want know how
everything-- how do I do this?
What's that?
Why?
How?
All the time, right?
And it's always
about the process.
And cooking with kids is
something they love to do.
So it often is
these little things.
So having that time, finding a
baker that will open themselves
up and take the kids in
and go through the process,
it's enormously rewarding
and fabulous and very easy
to actually do.
It just takes coordination.
And that's where
Make-A-Wish is brilliant.
GINA FLORESCU: That's also
a very interesting thing,
because the wish granters
that we have, they
have two that go in to visit
each child and talk to them
and get to know them and
really try to help figure
out what that wish is, not
that it's just a simple travel,
or they're not trying to
go through it quickly.
They're trying to get
to the bottom of what is
it that would make you happy.
And those ways granters
are always volunteers.
So they go in, and they
work, and they get to the kid
and figure out what
it is they want.
NIGEL BARKER: Who doesn't
want to be a genie?
MATT TARGETT: Seriously.
NIGEL BARKER: Right?
Come on.
I mean, it's like that's
the ultimate thing.
If you could be the genie,
how amazing is that?
And so really, Make-A-Wish
allows everybody
to become a genie for a moment.
And so that is a
very special thing.
MATT TARGETT: Yeah,
what a fun job.
I'm very envious
of your position,
but thank you so much for
coming into Google today.
I know you have to go
to your radio show.
And thank you so much for
coming to New York City
to help make a difference,
and thank you to the audience.
NIGEL BARKER: Thank you.
MATT TARGETT: And we'll
see you next time.
GINA FLORESCU: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]